to optimize training you need an optimum  recovery this means feeding your body  within 30 minutes of a workout when your  metabolism still high and your body's at  its most receptive using SAS rego  recovery range within these 30 minutes  gives you the full spectrum of nutrients  you need for high-intensity work  carbohydrate is your body's main source  of energy high GI carbohydrate is  provided to replenish your glycogen  stores fast digesting protein is  provided to rebuild muscle fiber and  promote lean muscle growth electrolytes  and water are provided to rehydrate  effectively try SAS rego rapid recovery  range to make the most out of your  training and be ready to go again  tomorrow